schedle uh State when the covid-19
quarantine
hit uh which was tragic because that was
that was a fun experience but then moved
into Supply Chain management and
Logistics uh was able to very
successfully Implement uh number of AI
and machine learning
uh uh implementations there uh for three
years that I was there and uh now I'm
kind of actually back mostly Consulting
in the uh Financial Services fraud
detection sort of space uh looking
primarily at uh identity fraud so that
is
me uh thank you so much for introduction
Jeremy and once again it's really good
to have you as always uh also as we move
on uh we'll be talking about careers in
EI machine learning in
2024 so here uh let's uh start with
hottest skills inl space in
yeah absolutely so um I'm sure many of
you if not all of you have heard of uh
chat GPT uh which is probably just the
most important or not important the most
popular example of uh kind of a large
language model in generative AI but uh
there are a number of different spaces
where this type of technology is being
used uh hugely
transformative uh not only has it
transformed I think the kind of
landscape of what's possible to do in
businesses but I think it very much
transformed the sort of like public
opinion and public awareness of
artificial intelligence um so you know
made it kind of I think more tangible
less
mysterious uh for some people less scary
for some people more scary uh but uh
yeah so all of that generative AI large
language models uh very much at the
center of a lot of applications and a
lot of um what I'm doing
today um prompt engineering is very much
a part of that so really in order to be
able to get the most out of your large
language model applications you have to
be very very careful in what exactly you
tell them to do and how exactly you tell
them to do it
um kind of outside of that though um
yeah there still is very much a need for
you know a lot of companies are looking
for people to help them with their AI or
data strategy overall uh
you know they kind of are aware of
things like generative Ai and large
language models and they know it's
powerful they know it's potentially very
useful uh and could potentially
transform their business but they're not
sure exactly how right uh they're not
exactly sure how that kind of thing
could be implemented uh how does it
really work for them what kind of data
do they need what kind of you know Tech
stack or environment do they need so uh
there's a lot of I think uh kind of
exciting stuff to do there in that sort
of Consulting space uh and then
yeah all this other stuff
actually uh I would say is just what
most data scientists do so deep learning
forecasting causal inference uh which
can sometimes be hard because in these
models we often find correlations but
correlations and causation are not
exactly the same thing so often
difficult to kind of uh really make
causal inferences there so your ability
to do that is often highly valued uh
distributed computing cloud computing uh
Big Data Technologies also very very big
uh given the volumes of data that we
have to deal with given the sort of
velocities of the uh machine learning
inferences that are required uh we do
look to the cloud for a lot of
Technologies there to support that so uh
yeah I would say all of these very
accurate uh list here very very accurate
list of hot skills and AI uh thank you
so much jery for taking us through the
hottest skills inl in 2024 uh so uh for
folks uh as you can see there are so
many skills uh jery has basically talked
about let us know if you are basically
uh learning any of these skills or
aspiring to learn any of these skills in
the coming year you can let us know in
the chart here I'll just give you one
minute in case you want to go through
this list uh as we have talked about the
skills here uh we'll be talking about
the career paths as well uh basically
the career paths which will be trending
in 2024 and much more in demand and have
been in demand so far as well
yeah absolutely
um so yeah I would say yeah data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers are always going to be highly
in demand and they're the ones that I
think kind of get talked about the most
they're sort of highlighted I think uh
the most in this space um and that kind
of I think leaves data Engineers as sort
of the unsung heroes of this space
unfortunately um definitely a very hot
job path to go down as well we
absolutely do need lots and lots of
capable data Engineers to be sure uh in
fact I would go so far as to say without
data Engineers around I probably
couldn't do my job uh so if I didn't
have someone making sure that I had
access
to Reliable data that's well understood
uh that's fit for purpose uh that kind
of
thing uh I would be basically stuck so
yeah data engineering
is always going to be needed it's always
going to be in demand uh and I think
it's probably just going to become even
more so um but then once you kind of
have that side of the coin right like
the whole point of having data engineers
and reliable well understood data sets
is so you can have data
scientists uh you know extract insights
from them uh that you know give you
actionable operational decisions um but
then once once you kind of have say a
model or an idea uh proof of concept
right for uh how that kind of thing is
going to be used and what kinds of you
know operational decisions can be made
from the data uh ultimately that must
you know kind of arrive at some kind of
software right so in order for it to be
useful it can't be something that's like
in a white paper or on a whiteboard
somewhere it's got to be software uh and
so these days a lot of that part of the
kind of life cycle of taking this idea
this proof of concept and ultimately uh
deploying it you know as an
enterprise-wide software solution that
very much uh falls under the purview of
the machine learning engineer uh the
mlops engineer so those guys are very
very important as well
um and I think probably the hardest one
of these to break into but it's one of
the most interesting is the artificial
intelligence uh researcher and developer
so data scientists machine learning
Engineers uh they make use of AI and
machine learning all the time but we
really are for the most part using
algorithms uh or maybe adapting
algorithms or kind of you know slightly
tweaking or building upon algorithms
that already exist and that are already
out there already quite well implemented
uh the AI engineer or sorry the AI
researcher and developer they're kind of
more on The Cutting Edge they're
developing these algorithms uh
publishing papers like that so that the
rest of us in the field are kind of
aware of these new techniques and and
what they can do and how to use them so
um exceptionally uh interesting and
high-paying uh career path but I would
say also the hardest one to break into
as
well uh totally agree uh as you speaking
Jeremy uh we actually asked folks who
have joined us which uh a career path
they are aspiring for in 24 and we've
gotten few responses here on the chart
as well uh I see AI developer is pretty
much in Dem man and uh yeah AA engineer
and architect yeah that one that one
absolutely I think you know in my time
in doing uh research uh is probably some
of my favorite time I've spent in
Industry um so yeah very fun very
lucrative very interesting uh but again
a lot of uh I would say a lot a lot of
hurdles you have to get over a lot of
barriers to entry uh that your employers
or potential employers will kind of look
SC or will demand uh when considering
you so so yeah you you got your work cut
out for you if you want to get into it
but uh absolutely you shouldn't let that
stop you if you want to do it you should
totally go for
it uh thank you so much for looking
through the ker path folks have
suggested uh and are resp sping for but
we have one question by Julie here about
which role is the most challenging uh
from I think from all what we have
discussed I'm
assuming
uh so there I'm not sure if it's really
possible to kind of make an Apples to
Apples comparison about which one is uh
the most challenging I would say in
terms
of uh your kind of like academic
requirements right like sort of those
sort of barriers to entry uh the
artificial intelligence researcher and
developer is probably the hardest one
there uh you'll often be expected to
have a PhD uh and some research EXP
experience there
um so there's that uh with data
engineering um you have to be very very
knowledgeable and experienced with
databases um distributed computing
systems you know things that have dealt
with very high volume High Velocity
data um you'll have to be aware of all
the different solutions for different
varieties of data so I've encountered
people that consider themselves data
engineers and they're like basically
like very very good at SQL they're like
SQL
ninjas uh but there's more to it than
just being very very good at SQL and
relational databases right you have to
be able to deal with like document based
databases Vector databases graph
databases then you have to be able to
recognize when you know uh when are we
dealing with data that's appropriate for
each type of of solution um you'll often
have to deal with streams of data from
iot uh you know different Edge Computing
devices and things like that so yeah
there's quite a bit that goes into Data
engineering uh which I think is partly
what makes it so challenging a friend of
mine actually kind of has this like
poster uh that sort of is like all the
different technologies that he deals
with as a data engineer and what they do
and uh it's got well over 300 different
Technologies on it so it's got like
Hadoop it's got spark it's got
um all these different ones scoop Flink
Cassandra uh I mean so there's just this
massive library of tools that you have
to be very well versed in to be a data
engineer uh on the other hand to be a
data scientist or a machine learning
engineer there aren't really so many
tools that you're going to use so you
don't need this like massive library of
tools to do what you do successfully but
the tools that you do use uh you do do
need to understand quite deeply uh
there's a lot more math and data science
so like my background I'm a
mathematician my degrees is in
mathematics not a lot of people like
that I I actually used to so I've been
in this field long enough that when
people would ask me what do you do if I
said oh I'm a data scientist people
would be like I have no idea what that
means uh nowadays everyone knows what it
means but uh back then I used to
introduce myself as a mathematician so
people would be like oh what do you do
and I'd say oh I'm a mathematician and
people would be like oh I hate math that
was like 99% of the time the response I
would get so if you don't like math the
data science uh category probably not
probably not for you probably not your
favorite um but yeah there's quite a bit
of math you have to be quite aware of
um sort of like uh experiment design
problems right like sample biases um
outliers you know different things like
that uh so that you're kind of aware of
any sort of confounding Factor
confounding variable uh that's gone into
your study or that's part of your model
or anything like that because uh yeah
it's not as simple as just sort of like
dumping data through you know some
canned model or something like that I
mean you have to really think carefully
about where the data coming from how are
they Rel related to other things what do
the data really mean about the business
process I'm describing and modeling here
um so yeah so they're they're all I
think potentially very challenging but
in very different ways so they're just
very different skill sets
uh thank you so much jery for taking us
through a much more detailed answer uh
for Julie here to what is exactly the
most challenging role uh but we are
getting a few more questions here also
JY we're live on YouTube as well and
folks there can also ask questions there
in the YouTube live chat box as well so
folks who have joined us on YouTube
please do let us know your questions in
the YouTube live chat box and just keep
it related to AIML in the program
because that is what this webinar is
about out and we'll try to address all
of your queries from YouTube as well as
we move on uh we have talked about the
skills here we have talked about the
carer paths you can take up in 2024 so
what exactly is stopping you from
becoming ANL practitioner or and also an
expert so you can see a quick poll
launched on your screen so uh you're
here because obviously you're interested
in a career inl as we saw so many
responses of what career path you are
already aspiring for in 2024 so uh
through this poll uh we would love to
understand what is the biggest challenge
you're facing when it comes to aspiring
for a career inl or becoming an AML
expert so uh this is a multiple choice
poll question as you can see you can
select multiple options because there
can be multiple uh basically challenges
or concerns right and also for folks who
have joined us on YouTube can let us
know on the YouTube live chat box uh if
this basically covers your concern I'll
just read out these options for you as
folks are already sharing the responses
for the poll here on Zoom uh so the
first one here is I can't find a program
with the fully comprehensive curriculum
second one I don't have the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready uh I
find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos the third one and
the last one my work schedule what allow
me enough time for learning so if this
covers your response uh you can
basically select it from the poll here
but if it does not cover your response
you can let us know in the Q&A box uh if
you have any other concerns here when
basically it comes to uh aspiring for a
career inl what challenge you're facing
exactly so as you have speaking we can
see that uh most of the folks have
shared the responses for the poll but I
think it'll just give five seconds more
uh for a few of the folks who are still
responding to the poll and also I am
keeping an eye on the YouTube live chat
box if you are have any questions for
folks who have joined Live on YouTube as
well you can let us know we'll take
questions from there as well
awesome I think uh I see most of the
folks have responded for the poll so let
me just quickly end the poll in 5
seconds last 5 Seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and also share the
results with you
folks uh as we can see that uh 53% of
the folks have voted for I can't find a
program with the fully comprehensive
curriculum and uh we can see that 48% of
the folks have voted for I wouldn't get
the Practical exposure I need to become
job ready 33% of the folks have voted
for my work schedule won't allow me
enough time for Learning and 15% of the
folks have voted for I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos and
few resp responses from the YouTube live
chat box as well so uh that's great um
let me uh move on to the program
introduction here quickly so we have
interesting program preview lined up for
you as promised and we'll be moving
towards the program preview of the UT
delis AIML learning boot camp so uh the
uist IML boot camp comes with a
comprehensive and Industrial learning
path you get access to integrated
integrated Hands-On labs and projects
which you can work on and choose to work
on from caption project as well uh you
get access to online live virtual
classrooms so not just pre-recorded
videos you get a live uh virtual
classroom where you can interact with
the instructor and uh it's pretty
engaging and also the program of
basically duration is of 6 months and
you can just complete it by giving uh 10
to 15 hours per week which basically
makes it very flexible uh for folks who
are working professionals which we saw
uh in the starting when we basically
asked for the experience poll right and
the learning format again will be online
and also a live instructor interaction
which I told you about um at the end of
it all you get a uis uh academic
Excellence boot camp certificate which
you can see on the screen here uh and
also the core and elective core
certificates uh also you get to be a
part of the UT Dallas Circle membership
and also a recognition and an online
convocation so now the online conv
convocation part makes it pretty
interesting because you not just
basically not just get to invite your
closest family or friends but you can
invite your basically all the the
friends and basically for our relatives
as well to attend your convocation so
that makes it pretty interesting uh to
get get first of all uh degree like from
UT dallis and also other core and
elective courses as well which you get
access to so now let's talk about the UT
delis Advantage here so UT delis uh
University of Texas at delis uh is a
renowned institution with the rich
history of academic Excellence it is a
home to a distinguished faculty members
and researchers fostering environment of
innovation and learning it is conly
recognized as a top tier research
University providing students with
access to cutting Ed knowledge and
resources and uh having a uist uh
basically certificate on CB is highly
respected and acknowledge globally which
basically will open doors to diverse
opportunities and networks a lot of
these career paths which we talked about
now moving on uh I think uh I think for
folks who have voted that they are
basically currently studying uh so this
is like eligibity and pites for them as
well to know that you can join this
program you need to just have a high
school diploma or equalent and be at
least 18 years of age in case you are in
doubt uh and also uh prior experience uh
in our knowledge of mathematics and
programming is required uh also you need
to have two or more uh years of work
experience which is preferred U and
basically I just have a question from
the audience here I think jery they
might be curious about this it says that
prior experience in mathematics uh sorry
prior experience in or knowledge of
mathematics and program coming so what
kind of experience or knowledge are we
expecting folks to have before they join
uh so I think before they join um rather
rather minimal probably you know uh just
classical algebra some things like that
are sort of what you're expected to have
coming in uh there actually is a math
primer uh that is offered for machine
learning um it's not part of the actual
sort of like you know core uh sequence
of the program but it's uh something
else that's just kind of offered a you
you know need to take it um but what
that will cover if you want to you know
really be able to understand and utilize
Ai and machine learning uh will cover
probability and
statistics
um to be honest we actually deal with
probability distributions
in uh quite High dimensional spaces as
well
um so kind of higher dimensional
statistics and probability basian
statistics especially
um then in order to be able to kind of
understand uh kind of how we do a lot of
our computations
efficiently um and also like what do I
mean by like higher dimensional right so
that's the thing that a lot of people
who don't have uh a lot of background in
mathematics like we live in this
universe that is at least apparently
three dimensions and so uh what does it
mean for something to have like a large
number of Dimensions um linear algebra
is actually the area of math that
defines that for you helps you
understand what that means and then also
gives you uh kind of the uh this this
knowledge of like matrices vectors uh
what do those kinds of computations look
like with those types of objects uh why
is that so efficient right like why do
we like doing things that way uh in
mathematics and in machine learning uh
then there's also some um uh
differential multivariable
calculus that's involved in machine
learning
so ultimately the way that we optimize
these algorithms involves taking
derivatives in multiple Dimensions the
actual word for that is we call it a
gradient uh so there's some work that
needs to go into knowing how to
calculate these gradients although that
I would say is
probably uh maybe the least essential
math skill that you'll need unless
you're actually doing research if you're
actually doing research you will need to
know how to do that you'll need to be
able to calculate those gradients if
you're someone who more just utilizes
models that other people have designed
um there are lots of software packages
out there that do auto differentiation
so that once you kind of have just set
up your model and the overall structure
of your model all of the gradients are
actually calculated automatically by the
software so whether you need to know
that or not kind of depends on what path
in AI or machine learning you're you're
really choosing to to
follow uh thank you for answering that I
hope that answers a lot of your uh
questions you might have in mind related
to having knowledge in mathematics and
programming please do let us know if you
have any questions more questions
related to that in the Q&A box uh and
also we've started getting a lot of
questions in the Q&A box that's great
we'll address your queries as soon as
possible uh whenever we get the time uh
and also for folks who have joined us in
YouTube can also let us know uh if you
have any questions we'll take it from
there as well so let's talk about how
this program prepares as you so I think
someone did ask that how exactly it
works right how how do we build these
skills to this program so let's talk
about how the program builds the a IML
skills uh step by
step yeah absolutely so uh starting at
the bottom this is cor of sort of the
where we begin uh so there's a sort of
an orientation session you can think of
this as almost like syllabus week right
like uh just kind of laying the ground
rules uh helping you understand like
what can you expect from the program
what does the program expect from you um
how do you go about getting help uh all
that kind of stuff right so uh there's
sort of this just uh you know higher
level uh introduction then we get into
the introduction to artificial
intelligence uh which helps you kind of
understand a bit of its history where
did it come from how has it developed uh
a little bit of kind of the Cycles so uh
I think fair to say at this moment we're
kind of in a bit of a hype cycle around
artificial intelligence uh not the first
one so artificial intelligence has been
hyped since the early 1960s uh to be
sure um and it's kind of gone in these
waves right we kind of go in these
periods where like people are just you
know way overhyped about it and then no
you know we hit hit a wall or we hit a
limitation of what we're currently
capable of and then interest drops off
and then no one cares about it for a
while and then we have some breakthrough
and then it comes roaring back and then
we have all this wild speculation and
hype about it so um I think it's
important to understand that that's
talked about a little bit um then we get
into oh then we get into uh applied data
science with python so this is some of
the really practical stuff that no
matter what area in you know AI or
machine learning you pursue you will
need to know some of these skills things
like uh data preparation so like
standardization normalization of data uh
dealing with missing values uh which
break most models uh outliers right
things like that right like so all of
the kind of proper techniques we're
dealing with those types of things um
then the course on machine learning is a
I think very good sort of General
introduction to machine learning and
this I would say you could call this
more like classical uh machine learning
so this gets you into some of the really
foundational models like linear
regression logistic regression uh
perceptrons and support Vector machines
decision trees random Forest
uh I believe we also talk about um naive
Bay classifiers um so basically a lot of
these kind of like very foundational
models that you really just you know if
you want to be able to call yourself a a
data scientist or an AIML professional
you just need to know about this stuff
uh then uh in the next course we get
into deep learning with Caris and
tensorflow so by Deep learning we
specifically mean deep artificial neural
networks um we help you define like what
is does that even mean like what do we
mean by that and then uh how do we build
these things and uh primarily we use
tensorflow and Caris which used to be
kind of a separate package but has
actually been incorporated into
tensorflow since 2.0 uh we're at like
2.15 now uh but yeah since since 2.0
Caris has actually been integrated as
sort of the um the primary syntax or API
for tensorflow so this is sort of the
industry gold standard for
uh implementing uh deep learning
Solutions uh then we kind of take that a
little bit further and get into
Essentials of generative AI prompt
engineering and chat
GPT uh this this particular course
doesn't get so much into like the deeper
theory of how a lot of these models work
you'll have kind of a beginning a sort
of like Foundation of how to understand
it because these are ultimately deep
neural
networks uh with a lot of different
other techniques Incorporated into them
uh things like attention mechanisms and
stuff like that so we we won't get into
that sort of stuff right those sort of
deeper topics uh but just some ideas of
you know what do these things do what
are they capable of what are they maybe
not so good at uh how do you kind of
squeeze more out of them especially with
the prompt engineering part because you
know the same model uh you know like say
you know GPT 3.5 or 3.5 turbo may give
you something totally you know perfect
and useful for what you want to do or it
may give you absolute garbage kind of
depending on how you ask for it so the
prompt engineering is like actually a
very key skill set to have when dealing
with these types of models uh and then
finally you get into the uh the Capstone
project which helps you kind of take
everything you've learned throughout the
whole entire boot camp and bring it
together in a very much you know kind of
work like you know real world uh
Hands-On type of project so that you can
and really kind of you know transition
from sort of book learning or you know
sort of book knowledge to actual
hands-on
experience um and that makes up the core
of uh the program itself you'll notice
kind of down on the bottom right we have
some elective options as well you don't
have to take these if you don't want to
uh or if your schedule is you know uh
too tight or whatever but uh if if you
would like you're actually allowed to
take these electives I strongly
recommend that you because there's a lot
of value in there so you can get
into um you know so it says like
Advanced deep learning and and Machine
Vision or computer vision uh if you'd
like to kind of specialize in that area
excellent class to take um natural
language processing and speak speech
recognition also excellent specialty to
kind of go into uh reinforcement
learning um people that actually are
Professionals in machine learning and AI
to be honest with you I would say about
80% of them are quite good at supervised
machine learning which you'll know more
about exactly what that means uh after
you've taken the course but um you know
so there are a lot more of them that
know about supervisor machine learning
and a little bit about unsupervised
machine learning uh reinforcement
learning is uh something that not very
many professionals actually know about
or have experience with but it is
essential to certain uh industry sectors
so like
robotics uh video games right so uh like
the sort of adversarial AI that you're
up against when you're playing a video
game uh also in finance right so like
algorithmic trading um a lot of these
sort of trading Bots which these days
more money is actually being managed uh
as we say passively right or uh by
machines than there are than there are
funds being managed by humans and uh the
most successful algorithms in this space
actually are reinforcement learning
algorithms where the machine actually
kind of learns more and more about kind
of how to play the game that it's
playing and um learns from its mistakes
learns from its successes and gets
better and better at what it's supposed
to do over time uh so very essential uh
you know skill set within machine
learning that again not very many people
have and that it exists in some highly
highly lucrative spaces so if you've got
time that's me personally that's the one
I would recommend you check out in the
electives is uh the reinforcement
learning uh course but you know again
depends on what you actually want to go
into but that's the one that I think is
kind of the
coolest um thank you so much JY for
taking through the steps here how this
program basically builds their uh skills
uh step by step also I think you have
already mentioned about the electives so
electives come as a part of the program
uh but they are completely optional uh
we don't charge anything extra for that
it is up to you if you want to take it
up as per your interest and as we move
on uh the tools and platforms you'll be
learning uh in the UT a cam as well uh
as you can see so many tools and
platforms we cover in this particular
course uh maybe jery you can show some
light on these folks who might not have
that much idea about uh these particular
tools which they will to learn in yeah
absolutely uh so there are a few
different programming languages that you
know might come up in a conversation
around data science or even machine
learning in AI uh things like
R uh I've actually strangely seen things
implemented in like you know mat lab or
uh G new octave but really the language
that is the sort of you know clear
leader at this moment uh the sort of de
facto lingua franka as they say for
machine learning is python 100%
so odds are if you're doing anything in
Ai and machine learning you're using
python uh within the data science world
there's actually a particular stack of
packages that make up the core of what
we do uh that's referred to as the numpy
stack um which includes map plot lib but
uh it's four packages primarily so it's
numpy itself which um very cleanly gives
us they call they call it an array but
basically it's a vector Matrix or a
higher rink tensors right so it gives
you that sort of data
representation uh within uh within
python
uh scipi which actually has all kinds of
it's sort of this catchall toolbox for
any kind of scientific Computing so a
lot of the uh probability
distributions um statistical tests um
signal processing there's a lot of
signal processing stuff in there which
we use a lot things like convolution or
uh low pass filters things like that
that come up in in different
applications uh and then we get pandas
which gives us access to data frames so
other Solutions like R actually natively
have a data frame as a just a native
data structure python actually does not
have that uh so pandas the pandas
package actually gives you a very robust
implementation of a data frame uh and
then map plot lib is actually our sort
of core package for making visual
visualizations so which is the thing we
do all the time because uh you know as a
data scientist yourself you have to make
visualizations just for yourself to
understand what's happening in the data
set you're working with but then also
that's really your most effective tool
for how you convey to other people like
what you found and what you've
understood in the data so uh that's very
big uh top right corner we have the nltk
or the natural language
toolkit uh that one as well as open CV
are a a bit more Niche so if you go into
the specialty of either natural language
processing uh or computer vision you'll
use one or the other of these right so
you'll use use either the natural
language toolkit or the open CV or open
computer vision Library
um then you have bottom right corner
let's talk about that pyit
learn uh excellent package it has very
robust very fast uh implementations of I
would say every uh basically
commoditized machine learning model uh
that's out there so that you have lots
of really great ways to implement those
uh tensorflow and Caris we've already
talked about those are great for deep
learning and then flask and Jango
actually are uh they're kind of an
alternative so you're either going to
use flask or you're going to use jeno uh
they get used a lot by web developers
but why we care about them in data
science is because uh either one of them
is actually a great way to build an API
so you won't always necessarily deploy
your models via apis it depends on what
the Need Is Right depends on exactly how
it's going to be consumed or or used by
people that that need it or systems that
need it uh but quite often uh your
deployment is going to be very event
driven so uh you know it's like when
this thing happens we need to be able to
then ask the model what to do so your
model is going to live in an API that
you know a call gets made to that API
and then your model makes a response and
that comes back so those either one of
those uh are are going to be what you
used to do
that uh thank you so much uh Jeremy for
taking us to the tools and platforms
here I think uh you also answered the
question by Hero year why we used python
in developments while you were answering
that as well so that we do have more
questions about eii in general we'll
take those uh so and also let's talk
about the cap projects as well they get
to work on uh through this uh UT IML
boot camp uh which they can showcase to
their future employers uh M making real
life business scenarios for True
experience uh also adding this to your
portfolio basically gives you that kind
of experience which you don't have uh if
you don't come from an IML background uh
also you get to choose from several uh
domains the project you get to work on
capstore uh um so I just have a question
that how does having a capston project
or also the industry based projects
which we have in this program how does
ex exactly help like when they basically
are done with the program and they start
working on these portfolio projects uh
for someone who does not have any
experience in the IML which we see a lot
of them right who have joined us here in
YouTube as well who who are live with
us yep absolutely
um let's see
here um I'm sorry I was answering a
question in the Q&A what was your
specific question uh yeah I was just
asking that uh we have gotten folks in
YouTube as well who basically are asking
uh basically Raja yadav is asking is it
good for non IT background guys as well
so now oh yeah yeah now this basically a
followup question with that that for
folks who basically have no experience
in it or AIML sector how how do they
showcase their uh real basically life
experience through these projects from
the program how does it exactly help
having these projects yeah so I mean in
order to be able to do the project uh
you're going to have to have learned
Python and uh learned it well enough to
implement the machine learning solution
in Python so I mean the fact that you
have completed the Capstone and
completed the the the boot camp would
mean that you know enough about python
to actually Implement one these
Solutions so uh absolutely it would
demonstrate that you have that you've
picked that that skill set up which is
important um I think you can come in
easily with sort of limited or minimal
it
experience I actually have often said
about data science specifically that
we're not necessarily like we're not
exactly it we often sort of get lumped
in with it in in a given organization
because there's not really a place
that's
better to to fit Us in but we're more it
adjacent than it specifically uh again
we're kind of
more you know mathematicians and problem
solvers right like so far more than you
know the programming or anything like
that uh I care far more about
understanding the actual business
problem um and then you know giving it a
formal mathematical structure so that we
know you know what are we after what
does success look like how do we measure
it uh what do the you know specific
inputs and outputs to the problem all of
that kind of stuff that's that's far
more important to you as a data
scientist than uh you know any of the
deeper it stuff and really you only care
about that because again in order for
the thing to be useful it does need to
be implemented as software um how much
you'll have to do that to be honest
really depends on the organization you
go into so there are some organizations
I've worked with where if they if your
job title is data scientists right uh
you're called the data scientist you are
expected to be able to implement your
own uh your own algorithm right so it's
like in some organizations They Don't
Really separate out the roles between
like machine learning engineer you know
mlops engineer and data scientist it's
like if you're the data scientist you do
all of it so if you work for an
organization like that yeah you'll
you'll need a pretty robust IT
background and you know you'll need to
be a very strong uh programmer and
developer but I've also worked for
organization
where uh they essentially allow their
mathemat or sorry their data science
team to basically be a bunch of
mathematicians uh you're kind of more
like an operations researcher applied
mathematician uh kind of professional
you really are just thinking about the
problem and mathematically what is the
optimal solution um maybe you'll write
up a white paper that describes it maybe
you'll code up like a proof of concept
that just logically shows like hey this
idea is correct this is working uh and
then at that point you will hand it off
to someone else with a much deeper IT
background who is going to then go
implement the thing that you came up
with
so uh I don't think that there's like it
would be nice if there was just like a
clean answer if I could just tell you
like oh you have to have exactly this
much python experience right but truth
is uh the industry isn't really
homogenized enough for me to tell you so
some places will expect you to have a
lot they'll expect it to be very very
proficient with python and not just with
python but with tools like Docker with
cloud Technologies uh all of that kind
of stuff because they'll expect you to
actually build and maintain your own
your own deployments um but if you're
not into that at all if you're just like
look that's not my background that seems
like a very hard thing for me to learn
um I just want to be like a
mathematician and a problem solver there
are organizations that are totally happy
to have you come in and do that as well
so it just depends on uh you know what
kind of company uh you're looking at I
think that also is um an important thing
for you to to think about as you're
looking for a job in this space right uh
a lot of the time people just worry
about like answering interview questions
correctly but remember like you're also
kind of interviewing the company right
like you're kind of interviewing them to
see if you want to work for them or to
see if it's a good fit on your side and
so that's a thing that you need to kind
of nail down with them as well like if
you're really looking for that that role
where you're not necessarily this like
really deep it
professional um you just you're you're a
little more on the mathematical side
then I think it's kind of you're sort of
obliged then to ask them about what are
the expectations as far as that goes
right do I have to deploy my own stuff
do I have to maintain all those
deployments do I have to build apis do I
have to like you know build build
software containers all that kind of
stuff or can I just build models right
uh so and again if they say like yeah we
expect you to build all that stuff you
probably won't get that job but you
probably don't want that job either so
on you know on the other hand if you're
like yeah that sounds great that's
exactly what I want to do then that's a
good fit right so it's kind of about
finding the company where their
expectation for what a data scientist is
matches up you know nicely with your
expectations about what a data scientist
is uh thank you so much for answering
that jery uh as we move on uh I think we
have talked about how exactly uh having
a capston project another industry
aligned projects uh basically helps your
portfolio when you come from a
completely a non it or non AIML
background as well so we have these
basically uh projects comprising of
Human Resources e-commerce automobile uh
food food service Healthcare and many
more uh industrial line projects which
we cover in this program which you
basically get to choose uh to work on
and uh as we've talked about the program
a lot uh we'll be taking through the
learning environment of the uist AIML uh
boot camp as well so jery you can feel
free to share your screen
and and meanwhile I just look through
the questions we have gotten because
gotten plenty questions in the YouTube
as well which we can answer ni sure so
I'll go ahead and take you guys
through the environment
here all right you able to see that
Russia uh yeah it's visible yeah cool
all right let's see so I've been
attached to a couple this one's probably
the closest to what we're talking about
here uh uh so uh yeah when you I guess
first log in you'll land at something
like this many of you uh will just have
the one boot camp uh that you're uh that
you're in uh so then you just click on
that and then this takes you to sort of
the dashboard of what it looks like so I
mentioned uh prerequisites
so uh if you
need uh kind of a refresher on
programming or on on math um I don't
know if the program refresher will
really be um necessary for this
particular boot camp that we're talking
about uh I don't think you're expected
to have any prior programming experience
but uh yeah so if you need kind of a
refresher on the math that'll be
there then in terms of the actual
courses
um they'll be listed here in order uh
again this course list is not exactly
the same as what we talked about it
actually will be what we talked about in
the slides but you know you have sort of
the uh
introduction uh to the the boot camp the
introduction to artificial intelligence
uh and then your other particular
courses which again these are not
exactly the same but very very close uh
and then finally this goes into the
Capstone uh in terms of like what a
specific course looks like uh let's see
here so you have your self-learning here
uh which gives you all kinds of videos
that you can watch uh my advice is that
um you actually can kind of watch these
in advance of showing up for class so it
makes it so that uh you're kind of
already a little bit familiar with the
the subject matter that's about to be
covered uh when it's time for your live
class you click on this little tab here
uh it'll actually have so this C this
session currently isn't running um but
uh you'll have all the dates that you'll
have classes along with the time and
then when it's timed actually log into
class there'll be this big blue button
down here at the bottom that says attend
class so you'll
actually jump in oh this is more like
what it'll look like if we look at past
classes so um you'll kind of have all
these calendar things here we may have
classes get moved around from for
Holiday considerations like we had Labor
Day here for this course uh but uh yeah
then you'll have your attend class
button down here um all of your
assessments and data sets you'll have
access to also down here uh then we also
have a lab
environment uh let's see if this one
still has anything in it I may
have all right so that's coming up so
this is actually our Jupiter lab
environment uh when I'm teaching I often
take um people through you know kind of
the implementation of the model live so
once we've kind of learned the you know
the math of how it works and how do we
set up you know how do we pre-process
the data all of that kind of stuff uh
then we'll actually just go ahead and
Implement that in Python uh right here
live in the
lab also though for your you know
assignments and and projects and things
like that that you'll have data sets to
work with and so this is sort of the
area where you'll oh good I do do have
this in here still I keep seeing a
message that this is going to go away
and it keeps being here that's awesome
uh so uh yeah so basically this makes it
so that you don't really have to worry
at all about setting up an environment
yourself so you don't have to think
about like your python version or any of
your package dependencies or any of that
like you already have a you know nice
robust environment that's been set up
for you in here so that it's all you
know working and everything like that
but uh yeah this in this particular
notebook this was an example of us going
through uh and building a couple of
different things so we built a feed
forward artificial neural network here
uh actually this is a class definition
so you'll learn more about this in the
boot camp but this is an actual like
proper objectoriented uh implementation
of the model so that uh uh this has all
of its methods that it needs for fitting
to data uh for getting predictions all
that kind of stuff we also to build an
auto encoder which is a specific
architecture for unsupervised
learning a lot of very useful
applications um oh gave a little example
of so there's a type of regularization
that we use in deep learning called
Dropout I particularly here implemented
uh what's called inverted Dropout I like
inverted Dropout uh myself um but uh
there's also just Dropout so showed them
what the code would have looked like if
we had just done you know vanilla
Dropout
then uh yep actually oh so I guess in
the version of this notebook we hadn't
finished out but then went ahead and
simulated some data a classification
data set and then shows how we then take
our class implementation fit the model
to the data get predict iics out of it
and then we also do a regression
example uh and then for comparison we
actually look at uh what does this
regression look like if we use linear
regression with an exponential basis
um again to kind of do some comparisons
in terms of like how accurate these two
models are relative to each other but
also how uh kind of intensive is the
whole exercise of uh you know trading
the two models right you'll find that
the the Deep neural network is
quite a bit more work to train than
linear regression uh so you kind of have
to make the assessment yourself about um
you know is it is it more accurate
enough that it's worth the extra
overhead and the extra hassle to uh to
develop it all that kind and to train it
and all that kind of stuff so uh yeah so
we as you can see we we kind of really
do get into it in here so and then
finally when you uh complete it you get
your certificate mine is locked because
uh I haven't completed this course as a
student I've just taught it as all uh
so yep so that is our whole entire oh
that's not our whole entire
uh environment as well we also have the
community so uh if you need you know
need help you know have any questions uh
things like that
then uh you
can uh go ahead and you know ask for
help on here uh I watch this as well so
uh if any of my students have posted
anything on here then I kind of find
their questions or if I have something
like a a notebook like the one that we
were just showing uh and everybody kind
of wants to be able to Tinker you know
play around with it maybe modify it a
bit uh I'll go ahead and post it on uh
the community board here so that people
can kind of have access to the notebook
that I wrote in class and then and mess
with it themselves
so um yep so that is it that is our
learning environment I'll go ahead and
give it back to you
Rasha uh sure thank you so much for
taking us through the learning
environment of the uis AIML boot camp uh
we do have few questions to answer but
uh let's quickly uh take them through
the learner outcomes here so uh the
previous classes have consisted of
Learners from World Class organizations
and diverse Industries Industries like
it software product manufacturing farma
Healthcare bfsi and many others and also
they come from companies like sap goich
Wells Faro Target Boeing HP IBM semens
infos and many other worldclass
organizations they basically join us
from also simply provides a career
assist Service as well which helps you
with your jobs you get access to free
access to expert webinars and career
events with industry leaders you get
options to choose from Real World
projects across Industries and create a
portfolio projects which we are disc
discuss pretty much in detail and also
the job assess Services uh in
association with Talent Inc uh that
starts uh at boot camp completion and is
valid for 6 months from uh basically
when you start once you completed uh the
boot camp um so we have talked about uh
the skills here I talked about the K
Parts here we do have one interesting
question on the YouTube live chat box
I'll just read it out for you Jen uh so
uh Rakesh here is asking after
dedicating 15 years into the IT field I
am contemplating a career shift towards
emerging Technologies like
mln uh would such a transition be
beneficial for my
career um so I would say that's
difficult to say uh without knowing more
about your specific uh you know
situation and uh things like that but I
would say you're certainly not alone a
lot of people that I have talked to have
been you know in the it you know devops
software engineering uh you know that
kind of thing uh they've been in a lot
of spaces in it and for whatever reason
either because of opportunity or you
know salary um you know terminal salary
comparisons that they've done things
like that they've ultimately decided to
get into data science and artificial
intelligence
so uh yeah so I I would say you're
certainly not alone in considering that
whether or not it's actually beneficial
depends on you know whether it would be
beneficial for you
specifically depends on where you're
currently at like you know kind of um
what level have you kind of reached in
your career in it um what are your sort
of like prospects in sort in terms of
like where else could you go uh versus
what do you kind of choose to do within
data science and ml uh I think there are
a lot of people that kind of make the
transition to data
science
uh how would I say this rather uh
haphazardly um so you know it's like
they just kind of look at it and they
think something like I'm just going to
throw numbers out there I don't even
know if these are like real numbers but
they'll look at it and be like Oh I'm
making like 880,000 a year doing what
I'm doing and I could make like 130,000
a year being a data scientist I'd rather
make $130,000 a year so I'll do that uh
and then they don't really think too
much about like well you know as a data
scientist you're essentially like
applied an applied mathematician with
some uh computer science you know stuff
thrown in there for good measure and
they get in there and they're kind of
like oh I hate math but I still want to
do this and there are a lot of people
out there today
unfortunately and you're all competing
with these people on the job market uh
that you know list themselves as data
scientists on their resume on their
LinkedIn on whatever else you know
they're claiming to be data scientists
uh but frankly they just want to make
more money they don't actually enjoy
data science work or being a data
scientist uh they've cut a lot of
corners and things like that so you know
uh to be honest I don't think those uh
individuals go very far I think uh their
employers find out rather quickly that
they you know don't really uh do great
work that they don't really enjoy you
know the kind of uh Daily Grind of being
a data scientist uh so yeah I I think if
you approach it that way or get into it
that way if it's more just about money
uh probably just stay where you are uh
you know or you know kind of continue
down the path that you're on uh on the
other hand though if things like you
know being an applied mathematician
solving business problems in that way uh
if that's all really fascinating and
interesting and cool to you then like uh
yeah I think you're gonna have a great
time being a data scientist and you know
an AIML professional um you know and if
there is more money then it's just sort
of the icing on the cake you know so
that's that's my opinion about it uh
thank you so much jery for answering
that I hope uh rakes it answers your
question uh we do have one more question
from paru Hill it's about the program as
well and uh she's sharing a little bit
about her experience as well I've shared
it on uh chart with you as well uh so
parul is asking that saying that I have
20 years of coding experience and
currently working on RPA technology what
e IML is uh course is good for me uh
should I go for a six month certificate
course or a degree course 6 months like
the util boot camp which we're talking
about and also has a followup question
as well how much time will uh be be
spending on the tools and the Platforms
in the boot camp
futters yeah absolutely so I would say
the
um the split in terms of like Theory
versus like
tools uh it's probably it leans a little
more toward the tools it's probably
about a 6040 split I would say um you do
need to learn some of the theory because
there's more to it than just like the
syntax uh to be honest there are tools
out there like pyit learn that have made
it ridiculously easy from a syntax
perspective you just really need to know
uh mostly the name of the algorithm that
you want to build right so if it's a
linear regression there's literally just
a linear regression Constructor uh and
then you have the data in the right
format and then you just once you've
created an instance of your linear
regression
class then there's a do fit method you
feed the data in and it fits the the
model to the data and then you need
predictions and so there's a do predict
method and literally everything in pyit
learn follows the syntax so it's like
the the the using the Tool uh at least
in that sense is quite simple uh very
straightforward and not hard to learn uh
the better question is again all of the
kind of theory for uh what is this
actually doing what are the assumptions
from a statistical perspective that I'm
making about the data by fitting this
model does the data set actually fit
those those assumptions uh if it doesn't
is there something I can do about that
um do I have missing data you know
missing observations do I have or
incomplete observations do I have
outliers um you know what do I do about
that um you know if I just throw out
things that are outliers or that are
missing am I biasing my study in some
way am I going to be confounding uh you
know confounding my my study or uh
giving bad predictions with my model uh
have I ensured that I'm actually getting
solid out of sample performance right
because it's all it's all well and good
to have your model be performing well
against the training data but then
you're going to actually deploy this
thing and your model's going to have to
make accurate predictions on new
observations it's never seen before so
uh has your model actually is your model
going to be able to generalize beyond
the training data as we say uh these are
all things that are important to know so
it's very very important to know about
the theory uh the tools I would say it
we definitely cover them absolutely we
do uh but I wouldn't stress so much
about that part of it that part's
actually I think a lot simpler than
you're uh than you're
anticipating uh thank you so much for
answering that joury uh par I hope that
answers your question uh please do let
us know if you have any follow of
questions uh in the Q&A box or in the
chat so as we have talked about the
skills here we've talked about the
projects here uh we also have job assist
Services by talting which I've mentioned
earlier which gives you access to the do
portal resume rabit and the resume
review and rewrite Services by top
resume and also a one-onone interview
service from Top resum as well so uh as
we have talked about the skills here the
career paths we have talked about the
caption and projects which you can add
to your portfolio we've talked about a
lot of industry based projects you get
to work on and just choose from which
you want to work on as a part of the
elective of the program as well we have
talked about the tools and platforms
we'll be covering in this UT AIML boot
camp as well which is of six months
duration so uh basically you can let us
know your interest in a quick poll which
I have just uh launched right now are
you interested in enrolling into the UI
utsl boot camp so you can select the
option yes in in case you're interested
and uh meanwhile folks who are sharing
interest towards enrollment into the UT
boot camp uh I'll be taking through the
enrollment steps of the program and also
the upcoming cohorts and also the
program fee for the uus AIML boot camp
as I'm speaking I see uh a lot of
interest coming towards enrollment
that's great uh folks I'll give you uh
10 to 15 seconds uh to basically share
your responses for the poll here uh
where you can let us know your interest
and based on that we can reach out to
you with the invests offer letter from
Simply Lear via util
list um meanwhile as you're sharing a
response for the poll here u j me we do
have we do have one more question uh if
you can see on the chart here I've
shared it from the Q&A box uh I'm not
able to make out the name of the person
uh but I'm just going to read out the
question uh this person has how long is
uh basically the ml program for someone
without PRI knowledge of python or any
other programming language
skill uh let's see so the well the
program I mean is as long as it is uh I
think maybe uh your your question might
just be about kind of uh you know how
how well are you going to be able to
kind of like survive in the program if
you have like no programming experience
uh I have had students who came in with
no programming experience at all or
they're you know uh they're in a
situation where they're like oh I you
know I did some programming like 20
years ago when I was in school but I
haven't done any programming since then
so I'm basically starting over um that
can be a challenge to be sure uh you
know and that that's a thing that you
kind of have to evaluate for yourself
uh if you're going to have the time if
you're going to have the extra time uh
and the energy to kind of put into
catching yourself up um
so yeah I've I've seen people
absolutely uh
succeed coming in without you know any
prior programming experience or anything
like that but they definitely have to
put in a bit of extra work to cat
themselves up in uh in that particular
area so it can be hard uh it certainly
is harder if you don't have
um the programming experience but 100%
doable um and if you take advantage as
well of things like office hours things
like that uh your instructor absolutely
uh can take the time to to help you kind
of get up to speed as quickly as
possible uh thank you so much for
answering that I hope uh that answers
your question please do let us know if
you have any followup question for us in
the Q&A box also folks as you can see U
I'll give 10 seconds more for the folks
here because I see the polls are still
moving so you can see a quick poll on
your screen here where we would love to
know your interest in enrolling into the
UT boot camp and as we are taking more
questions uh which we have gotten from
uh the zoom uh Q&A box here and also
from the YouTube live chat box so we
have one more interesting question uh
I'm not able to make out name from the
username but uh interesting question um
and seeing that I am more than willing
to learn uh to get into this field uh
would my experience within cyber
security help me with the boot
camp uh absolutely I would say that
would help um and Not only would that
help you with the boot camp uh but I
think that actually gives you kind of if
you're if you're still interested in
cyber security like if you find that
kind of thing interesting and cool um Ai
and machine learning actually are
heavily applied uh to that space um so I
think picking up Ai and machine learning
as part of your you know your skill set
and your toolbox uh you know and kind of
having a focus on that
area is I think a killer route to go
down you know they're you know very very
lucrative very exciting very fun um so
you know it's a lot of the same are very
similar I would say to where I'm at
where I'm you know looking into identity
fraud using a ml to detect identity
fraud in new account applications and
things like that um you know you're
actually more looking for things like
fraudulent login attempts
uh so if someone's trying to say do like
a credential stuffing attack against the
login portal uh you can absolutely train
Ai and ml solutions to detect that kind
of thing and cut the traffic off um
things like that so yeah if you are
already special isend that area and then
you want to learn how to take Ai and ML
and apply it to that area like that's
huge I think that's going to be you know
a thing that you'll have a lot of
success
with thank you so much for answering
that Jimmy I hope that answers your
question uh we have taken this question
from the YouTube live chat box I think
last 5 seconds for the poll here uh
which I can see a lot of interest
towards enrollment into the util AML
boot camp so last 5 seconds for are you
interested in rolling into the utilus
AML boot camp so you can quickly at us
know by sharing your response as yes in
the poll here and I'll be taking to the
enrollment steps of the program very
quickly we have exceeded the time of the
session by a few minutes we'll try to uh
just uh cover it quickly because we have
answered most of the questions we have
gotten uh throughout the session so last
5 Seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and uh take you through the
enrollment steps of the program here so
the program fee I think someone asked
about what what is the program fee of
the utl boot camp so it is $8,000 USD
and uh we do have Emi financing options
also available for as low as $74 per
month uh in case you need more
assistance you can reach out to us at
ask us at s.net I'll just share that
email ID for you on the chat here as
well uh just allow me a second and also
talking about the cohort here I'll be
sharing the upcoming cohort for the utl
boot camp and also asking you when are
you planning to enroll as well just to
give get a ballpark idea so we can know
basically when to reach out to you with
the admissions offer letter and a much
more detailed walkth through of the
program uh but in case uh you need any
assistance you can reach out to us ask
us at s.net also we uh take very limited
set of folks per cohart in order to make
sure you're getting all the attention
that is required when you're taking up
this program uh and the upcoming cohat
the classes start on January 8th 2024
that is next year and also the induction
also starts at January 8 2024 uh the
learning Consultants from Simply Lear
will be reaching out to you and they'll
be taking you through these three simple
easy steps uh for enrollment uh you need
to submit an application to us at ask
us.net which I've shared with you on the
email ID here and based on that your
application be going for review and
based on that you'll be getting
admissions offer from learning
Consultants from Simply learn so now
that I've shared with you the program
fee and the upcoming cours uh and also
the schedule as well uh we would love to
know uh when uh how soon do you plan to
enroll uh into the you you ousl boot
camp can see four quick options here uh
immediately within 3 months within 6
months more than 6 months from now uh I
have shown the upcoming cohort which is
on January 8th uh if you in case you're
planning to join join the immediate coh
you can join that one and apart from
that we do have like upcoming CTS
throughout the year so you can select
any of the last three options as well in
case you're not sure exactly when are
you planning to join so uh this way we
will get to know basically when uh can
we reach out to you uh for the
admissions offer and also take you
through the admission uh process as well
from Simply LS learning Consultants so
uh I'll just give 10 seconds for the
poll here uh so uh folks we have tried
addressing all of your queries here uh
with with the amount of time we have
gotten uh we do have exceeded uh time
just to address uh your your queries as
much as possible um so I will just
quickly uh basically uh go towards the
end of the session after this after
knowing if you need any assistance in
enrolling to the program so last five
seconds for the poll here which you see
on the screen uh how soon do you plan to
enroll in the udist AIML wood Camp so 5
4 3 2 1 one let me quickly end the poll
thank you so much for sharing uh that
with us and now we move on to the last
poll of the session which is if you need
assistance in enrolling uh into the uis
AML boot camp so this is for folks who
have already shared uh interest with us
uh for enrollment which I saw a lot of
you and this is for basically folks who
have already shared interest in
enrollment and also have let us know
when do you plan to enroll as well so uh
if you need uh more assistance in
enrollment uh in case you're walking
professional you're very busy and you
can't basically go through all the steps
by yourself definitely we'll help you
out with that and other things which you
need help with in terms of enrolment
into the udl boot camp so quickly go and
share the response here uh yes or no in
case you need assistance it can be yes
if no then you can choose the option
no so uh um I think I'll just give five
seconds for the poll here um because I
see folks have already started sharing
their responses here and uh we basically
are towards the end of our session today
so last five seconds for the folks here
do you need assistance in enrolling into
the AML bootcamp so uh let me quickly
end the poll and uh move on towards the
end of the program here so uh first of
all thank you uh for everyone for
joining and being a very active audience
we have got in a lot of interesting
questions both from YouTube live and
also from the zoom uh Q&A box and the
chat box as well so uh jery would first
of all love to thank you and it's always
a pleasure to host you and uh seeing you
basically take us through these plround
reviews uh would you like to see
something the folks here before we end
the
session yeah absolutely so uh yeah
thanks everybody thanks for being
patient and sticking with us while we uh
you know answer as many questions as we
can and uh you know I realize we got
went a little bit over one last thing I
do want to say so this is something that
we mentioned uh although we mentioned it
rather quickly but I think it kind of uh
Bears highlighting so uh I think a lot
of our students that I've seen they get
a lot out of the courses they get a lot
out of the projects and and things like
that and then unfortunately they tend to
kind of
underutilize the other things that are
offered in the program such as the you
know kind of um you know interview
coaching a sort of job placement part
after that uh so if this is a thing that
you're interested in and you you choose
to do this uh absolutely do not uh you
know pass up on you know taking
advantage of those things that are
offered I think that part's huge in fact
that's maybe one of the kind of biggest
um kind of value ads in the program
right so the knowledge is important
because that's what's going to make it
so that you are able to do the job once
you have a job uh but you still need to
get the job right and I've a lot of
people that are brilliant they're so
smart uh they're you know good at the
math they're good at the programming
they know what they're doing they would
make a great data scientists but they
just fall apart in interviews right they
just don't interview well they don't
present well the resume Is Not Great you
know things like that uh which can
really make the difference between
whether you get in front of an
interviewer or not or you know whether
you kind of pass the interview or not
and get the job so yeah that's again
really high value thing that was that
was I think talked about and that
unfortunately a lot of people forget
that we do uh once they're in the
program so yeah if you're you know
really struggling if you're like I'm not
I haven't been able to get a job I'm you
know not able to get in front of people
or whatever uh absolutely check back
into you know taking advantage of that
part of the program because I think that
that part's really huge and a lot of
people forget we do it
so I definitely agree with that and uh
Jeremy like I think we would love to
hear from you uh someday about your
experience of uh interviewing
and and
also on interview prep as well forl uh
so maybe for the upcoming year we would
we would love to know your I think we
don't absolutely for sure for the next
webinars as well so thank you so much uh
jery once again for everyone who have
joined us thank you once again folks uh
have a good evening uh good afternoon
wherever you joining us from and a good
night for folks who have joined from
India so thank you so much folks thank
you thank you
Vis thanks everyone see
you